There's even a little
bit more that we can
learn about our energy diagram.
And I'd like to just clean this
diagram up for a little second,
because I want to
work in this area.
Suppose our system, because
the work non-conservative is 0,
tells us that the mechanical
energy is constant.
Now we don't know how much
mechanical energy our system
is.
That's a constant of the system.
But let's just suppose
that our mechanical energy
is written like that.
And we'll just
clean up a little,
give ourselves a little space.
So here is the mechanical
energy of the system,
and that's a constant.
And now we can talk about
two more special points.
A point over here,
and at this point,
let's just think about what
our mechanical energy tells us.
This is a special point,
but let's begin with one
right here.
If our particle is
at this location,
then this represents
the potential energy
and the difference between the
energy and the potential energy
is the kinetic energy.
So this here represents
the kinetic energy.
And now we can
ask ourselves what
would happen to the energies
as our particle is moving?
So if we start right here,
the kinetic energy is 0.
Because all the
potential energy,
all the energy is potential.
And as a particle
starts to move,
let's say it has a
little bit of energy.
It starts to move
in this direction.
Then the kinetic energy
starts to increase
until we get to this point,
where the kinetic energy is
maximum at the
stable equilibrium
point where the force is 0.
Now the kinetic energy
decreases because remember,
it's now going
against the force.
The side the force was
pointing in that direction.
Here it was in the
other direction.
And until we finally
get to this point
where, again, the
energy of system
is equal to all
potential energy,
and so there is
no kinetic energy.
So I'll call this
point A, and I'll
refer to this point
over here, diagram
is getting a little
crowded, as B.
And those points
A and B are what
we call the turnaround points.
And they represent the places
where the kinetic energy at XA
is equal to the kinetic
energy at XB, which is 0.
Now the last thing
that we like--
there's a lot of
information, as you can see,
contained in these
energy diagrams.
And the last bit of information
that we'd like to ask ourselves
is what would happen if
instead of having-- confining
our system to this area, we
increased our mechanical energy
so we're up here.
And let's just
follow qualitatively
the motion of a
particle that begins
say, over here, with a
little bit of kinetic energy
and potential energy.
And if the particle starts
off with the velocity
in the positive x
direction, then it's
going to move in this direction.
And you can see the kinetic
energy is increasing.
Here we have a maximum
amount of kinetic energy.
But notice that over
here the particle still
has some positive
kinetic energy,
and so it can get
over this hill.
And when it gets
to the other side,
the force was in the
positive direction.
It increases its kinetic
energy, and it goes off
to what we're referring
to as infinity.
So one analogy that
people like to make
is to understand the motion,
think of a marble that's
rolling down a hill.
And this is just a metaphor for
this potential energy function.
As the marble rolls down the
hill, it gains kinetic energy.
It loses potential energy.
It comes maximum at
the bottom of the hill.
As it goes up the hill, it
still has enough kinetic energy
to get over the top of
the hill and to start
to come down the other side.
And of course, our
particle can never
get to the speed of light.
So our model has to
break off at one point.